a German Shepherd is finally back home
with his family this morning after
United Airlines sent him halfway across
the world by mistake whoops
ergo flew back to the US and a charter
plane last night
United sent the family these photos to
update him on his status the whole trip
he was supposed to land in Kansas City
with his owners on Tuesday but as you
may have heard United flew him to Japan
instead letter modu da of our streaming
network cbsn is here with the family
reunion well at least he got to go to
Japan I've got to go to Japan and I got
banner dog reunited yeah it's been a
very costly week for United Airlines and
not just in terms of public relations an
average charter flight like the one ago
took from Tokyo to Wichita is more than
90 thousand dollars and while the family
is happy to have their dog back they are
looking for answers to how this happened
the swindle family was all smiles as
they reunited with their dog Urgo at the
Wichita Airport last night the 10 year
old German Shepherd arrived after an
unplanned cross Pacific flight to Japan
I feels absolutely amazing to finally
have him back it's been a long four days
Karis window and her family are
relocating to Kansas from the west coast
but when they went to pick up her go
from the Kansas City Airport on Tuesday
United Airlines gave them a different
family's dog instead I walked over to
the kennel and I called his name and up
popped this Great Dane instead of my
German Shepherd and it was just instant
tears because this wasn't my dog and I
had no idea where my dog was it has been
the absolute worst nightmare we already
have so much going on and then to throw
this into it I don't know how much I can
take this comes after a ten-month old
Bulldog died on a United plane earlier
this week when the owners say a flight
attendant made them put him in an
overhead bin United transported more
than 130,000 animals last year 18 of
those died and 13 were injured a much
higher rate than any other airline
United has apologized for the mistake
and flew her go back on a private jet
but kara says it's not enough
I hope they somehow put into some policy
that this never happens again just so we
can make sure then nobody ever goes
through this again
because what I have felt the last couple
days I don't want any other dog owner to
ever feel again not knowing where your
beloved pet is it really is a nightmare
as for the Great Dane Lincoln he arrived
back in Japan yesterday United Airlines
is still investigating how the mix-up
happened and have not released any new
information they say the dogs were
switched during their connection in
Denver kara says that if they travel
with or go again it's gonna be on a boat
not a plane you see where that's
upsetting to the family because really a
dog is like a member of the family
indeed really dog lover thank you guys